>> Laura: IT'S FRIDAY.
THAT MEANS IT'S TIME FOR FRIDAY
FOLLIES.
THE DEMOCRATIC DEBATE PROVIDED
US WITH MORE RIDICULOUS AND
HYSTERICAL MOMENTS WE COULD
IMAGINE.
RAYMOND ARROYO, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR.
YOU NOTICED SOME TRENDS OF THE
DEBATE THAT AUDIENCES MIGHT HAVE
MISSED.
>> I DID.
THE FIRST THING WAS THE ATTEMPT
TO SUBTLY LAY CLAIM TO A
FAVORITE PHRASE OF A FORMER
PRESIDENT AS A WAY TO BUILD
STATURE.
IF ONLY THEY COULD HAVE BEEN
CLEARER.
>> FIRST OF ALL, LET ME BE VERY
CLEAR.
>> LET ME BE CLEAR.
>> LET'S BE CLEAR.
>> LET'S BE CLEAR ABOUT THIS.
>> LOOK, LET'S JUST BE CLEAR.
>> TWO THINGS BECAME CRYSTAL
CLEAR FOR ME.
>> LET ME BE VERY CLEAR.
>> Laura: VERSUS LET'S BE FUZZY
RIGHT NOW.
OBAMA ALWAYS SAID THAT.
>> HE DID INDEED.
AS WE'LL REMIND YOU.
>> SO LET ME BE CLEAR.
>> LET ME BE CLEAR.
>> NOW, LET ME BE CLEAR -- LET
ME BE ABSOLUTELY CLEAR --
>> JOE BIDEN MENTIONED OBAMA SO
OFTEN, LAURA, I THOUGHT HE MIGHT
BE RUNNING FOR A THIRD TERM.
LISTEN?
>> I KNOW THAT THE SENATOR SAYS
SHE'S FOR BERNIE, WELL, I'M FOR
BARACK.
THIS PRESIDENT HAS DONE A GREAT
DEAL.
SO I'M PROUD TO HAVE SERVED WITH
HIM.
BARACK TURNED THEISH THE
PRESIDENT TURNED TO ME AND SAID,
JOE, WITHE HAVE A PLAN TO GET
OUT, HE TURNED TO THE WHOLE
SECURITY AND SAID, JOE WILL
ORGANIZE THIS.
>> BIDEN EVEN RELEASED AN AD,
LAURA, TO REENFORCE THE
RELATIONSHIP IN CASE YOU FORGOT.
>> BARACK OBAMA IS AN
EXTRAORDINARY MAN.
>> I WATCHED UP CLOSE HIS
CHARACTER, COURAGE, AND VISION.
>> HE WAS A GREAT PRESIDENT.
I WAS PROUD TO SERVE AS HIS VICE
PRESIDENT.
>> THEN SOMETHING HAPPENED ON
STAGE, BIDEN COULDN'T RECALL WHO
THE PRESIDENT WAS?
>> I HEAR THE LARGE -- THE
PRESIDENT SAYING -- MY FRIEND
VERMONT THINKS THAT THE EMPLOYER
IS GOING TO GIVE YOU BACK IF YOU
NEGOTIATE THE UNION ALL THESE
YEARS?
HE CALLED BIDEN -- HE CALLED
SANDERS THE PRESIDENT THERE.
THE POOR MAN.
I -- MY HEART ALWAYS BREAKS FOR
HIM.
HE'S SO EARNEST.
>> Laura: WAIT A SECOND.
HE'S SO EARNEST?
>> HE IS EARN E
>> HE IS EARNEST.
>> Laura: I KIND OF LIKE BIDEN.
I HAVE TO SAY.
>> HE WANTS IT SO BADLY.
THE BLOOM IS OFF OF THE LILLY
HERE.
>> Laura: THE GLORY DAYS ARE
DONE.
THE SPRINGSTEEN SONG HAS PASSED
YOU BY.
>> YEAH, A MOMENT.
>> Laura: THINGS WENT OFF OF THE
RAILS FOR BIDEN WHEN HE STARTED
TO OFFER PARENTING ADVICE TO
LOW-INCOME KIDS.
>> PLAY THE RADIO.
MAKE SURE THE TELEVISION --
EXCUSE ME, MAKE SURE YOU HAVE
THE RECORD PLAYER ON AT NIGHT,
THE PHONE -- MAKE SURE THE KIDS
HEAR WORDS.
>> Laura: THAT ANSWER TO A
QUESTION.
>> THIS WAS A PIVOT FROM A
QUESTION ABOUT REPARATIONS.
AND HE WAS TRYING TO GET TO HIS
PLAN, WHICH IS A HOME VISITATION
PLAN WHERE PEOPLE COME IN AND
HELP KIDS -- TALK TO THEM, GIVE
THEM LANGUAGE.
SO HE WAS SAYING PUT THE RADIO
ON,
>> Laura: I'M HERE FROM THE
GOVERNMENT, I'M HERE TO RAISE
YOUR CHILDREN.
NO THANKS.
>> IT'S PART OF THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT.
THEN THERE WAS BIDEN'S
UNFORTUNATE UPPER PALATE ISSUE.
OH.
>> FOUR MONTHS AFTER SANDY HOOK,
A MEASURE TO REQUIRE BACKGROUND
CHECKS DIED ON THE SENATE FLOOR.
IF YOU COULDN'T GET IT DONE
AFTER SANDY HOOK, WHY SHOULD
VOTERS GIVE YOU A CHANCE.
>> I GOT IT DONE BEFORE.
I'M THE ONLY ONE THAT'S EVER
BEAT THE NRA.
>> POOR MAN, I HOPE POLIDENT ARE
THE NEXT SPONSORS OF THE DEBATE.
THERE'S KAMALA HARRIS WHO LOOKED
LIKE -- SHE WAS VERY RELAXED.
>> Laura: SHE 45D A COOL WAY
OF -- IT WAS KIND OF A --
>> SHE HAS ADMITTED TO SMOKING
WEED.
>> Laura: OH, SHE WASN'T.
WE'RE JOKING.
SHE LOOKED --
>> I'M JUST SAYING.
>> Laura: SHE ADMITTED THAT IN
THE PAST.
>> WATCHES IT, VERY RELAXED.
>> DONALD TRUMP IN OFFICE ON
TRADE POLICY.
HE REMINDS ME OF THAT GUY IN THE
WIZARD OF OZ, YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU
PULL BACK THE CURTAIN, IT'S A
SMALL BOOT.
>> NOT GOING TO TAKE THE BAIT.
>> I WOULD SAY, HEY, JOE,
INSTEAD OF SAYING THAT WE CAN'T,
LET'S SAY YES WE CAN.
>> SHE WAS REAL LAID BACK LAST
NIGHT.
>> Laura: I THOUGHT SHE WAS
PRETTY GOOD.
>> YOU THOUGHT KAMALA HARRIS WAS
REALLY GOOD?
WAIT A MINUTE, YOU JUMPED ME FOR
DEFENDING JOE BIDEN, EARNEST JOE
BIDEN AND DEFEND KAMALA HARRIS.
>> SHE'S ALL OVER IT.
>> WIZARD OF OZ.
>> I LIKE THAT.
I LIKE THAT.
IT'S LIKE A SLOW ROLL.